the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're going to keep on going with
related rates and you may recall the
last time we were in the middle of a of
a problem with this geometry there was a
right triangle
there was a road which is going this way
from right to left and the police were
up here monitoring the situation 30 feet
from the road and you're here and you're
heading this way it's so maybe it's a
two-lane highway but anyway it's only
going this direction and this distance
was 50 feet so because you're moving
this distance is varying and so we gave
it a letter and similarly your distance
to the foot of the perpendicular with
the road is also varying at this instant
it's 40 because this is a 3 4 5 right
triangle so this was the situation that
we were in last time and we're going to
pick up where we left off the question
is are you speeding if the rate of
change of D with respect to T is 80 feet
per second technically that would be
minus 80 because you're coming you're
going towards the the policeman all
right so D is shrinking at a rate of
minus 80 feet per second and I remind
you that 95 feet per second is
approximately the speed limit which is
65 miles per hour
so again this is where we were last time
and put a little question mark there and
so let's solve this question this
problem alright so
this is the setup there's a right
triangle
so there's a relationship between these
lengths and the relationship is that x
squared plus 30 squared is equal to d
squared so that's the the first
relationship that we have and the second
relationship that we have we've already
written down which is DX DT oops sorry
DD DT is equal to minus 80 all right now
the idea here is relatively
straightforward we just want to use
differentiation
now you could you could solve for X all
right X is the square root of d squared
minus 30 squared all right that's one
possibility but this is this is
basically a waste of time it's a waste
of your time so so it's easier or
easiest to follow this method of
implicit differentiation which I want to
encourage you to get used to namely we
just differentiate this equation with
respect to time now when you do that you
have to remember that you are not
allowed to plug in a constant namely
4040 you have to keep in mind what's
really going on in this problem which is
that X is moving is changing and D is
also changing so you can't you have to
differentiate first before you plug in
the values so the easiest thing is to
use in this case implicit
differentiation and if I do that I get
2x dx/dt is equal to 2 d D D DT no more
D DT left
we hope but except in this blackboard
alright so there's our situation now if
I just plug in now I can plug in
in values so this is after taking the
derivative and indeed we have here two
times the value for X which is 40 at
this instant and then we have DX DT and
that's equal to 2 times D which is 50
and then D D DT is minus 80 all right so
the ATS cancel and we see that DX DT is
equal to minus 100 feet per second and
so the answer to the question is yes
although probably wouldn't be pulled
over for this much of a violation all
right so that's right it's more than
than 65 miles an hour by a little bit
okay so that's the end of this question
and usually in these rate of change or
related rates question this is
considered to be the answer to the
question if you like all right so that's
one example I'm going to give one more
example before we go on to some other
applications of of implicit
differentiation so my second example is
going to be you have a is a conical tank
okay with top of radius 4 feet let's say
and depth 10 feet okay so that's our
situation and then it's being filled
with water so is being filled with water
at 2 cubic feet per minute all right so
there's our our situation and then the
question is how fast
is the water rising when it is at depth
five feet so if this thing is half-full
in the sense well not not have full in
terms of the total volume but have full
in terms of height what's the what's the
speed at which the water is rising okay
so how do we set up problems like this
well we talked about this last time the
first step is is to set up a diagram and
variables and I'm just going to draw the
picture I'm actually going to draw the
picture twice so here's the conical tank
and we have this radius which is four
and we have this height which is 10 so
that's just to allow me to think about
this problem now it turns out because we
have a varying depth and so on and and
and this is just the top that I better
depict also the level at which the water
actually is at present and furthermore
it's better to do this schematically as
you'll see so the key point here is to
draw this triangle here which shows me
the 10 and shows me the 4 over here and
then imagine that I'm filling it partway
so we'll maybe we'll put that water
level in in another color here so here's
the water level and the water level I'm
going to depict that horizontal distance
here as R that's going to be my variable
that's the radius of the top of the
water so I'm taking a cross-section of
this because that's geometrically the
only thing I have to keep track of
least initially alright so this is this
is a water level and it's really of
rotated around but I'm depicting just
this one half slice of the of the
picture and then similarly I have the
height which is this dimension there
that that or if you like the depth of
the water so the water has filled us up
up to this point here so I set it up
this way so that it's clear that we have
two triangles here and that one piece of
information we can get from the geometry
is the similar triangles information
namely that R divided by H is equal to
4/10 okay so this is by far the most
typical geometric fact that you'll have
to glean from a picture ok so that's
that's one one piece of information that
we get from this picture now the second
thing we have to do is set up formulas
for the volume of water and then figure
out what's going on here so the volume
of water is of a cone so again you have
to know something about geometry to do
many of these problems so you have to
know that the volume of a cone is 1/3
base times height now this one is upside
down the bases on the top and the and
it's going down but it's works the same
way that doesn't affect volume so it's
1/3 and the base is PI R squared that's
the base and times H which is which is
the height all right so this is the
setup for this problem and now having
our relationship we have one one
relationship left that we have to
remember because we have one more piece
of information in this problem namely
how fast the volume is changing it's
going at two cubic feet per minute
it's in
so that means that dv/dt is - all right
so I've now gotten rid of all the words
and I have only formulas left all right
I started here with the words I drew
some pictures and I derive some formulas
actually there's one thing missing
what's missing yeah exactly
what you want to find what I left out is
the question so the question is what is
dhdt when H is equal to five all right
so that's that's the question here all
right now we've got the whole problem
and we never have to look at it again if
you like we just have to pay attention
to the two this piece here all right so
let's carry it out so what happens here
so look you could do this by implicit
differentiation but it's so easy to
express R as a function of H that that
seems kind of foolish so let's like
write R is two-fifths H all right that's
coming from this first equation here and
then let's substitute that in that means
that V is equal to 1/3 pi times 2/5 H
squared times H and now I have to
differentiate that so now I will use
implicit differentiation
it's very foolish at this point to take
cube roots and to solve for H you just
get yourself into a bunch of junk so
there is a stage at which we're still
using implicit differentiation here I'm
not going to try to solve for H as a
function of V instead I'm just
differentiating straight out from this
formula which is relatively easy to
differentiate so this is DV DT which of
course is 2 is equal to and if I
differentiate it I just
this constant pi over three this other
constant two-fifths squared and then I
have to differentiate H cubed right H
squared times H so that's three H
squared times dhdt all right that's the
chain rule all right so now let's plug
in all of our numbers again the other
theme is you don't plug in numbers of
fixed numbers until everything has
stopped moving at this point we've
already calculated our rates of change
so now I can put in the numbers so two
is equal to PI over three times two
fifths squared times three and then H
was 5 so this is 5 squared and then I
have dhdt
there's only one unknown thing left in
this problem which is dhdt everything
else is a number and if you do all the
cancellations you see that this cancels
this one of the twos cancels well this
cancels this and then one of the twos
cancels that so all told what we have
here is that d h dt is equal to one over
two pi all right and so that happens to
be feet per second and this is the the
whole story all right question way back
there where did I get the question is
where did I get R equals 2/5 H from the
answer was it came from similar
triangles which is over here I did this
similar triangle thing and I got this
relationship here R divided by H is
equal to 4/10 but then I cancelled but
got 2/5 so so and brought the H over
another question over here
the question was the following suppose
you're at this stage can you write from
here DVD H so suppose you're here and
work out what this is which is it's
going to end up to being some constant
times times H squared and then also use
DV DT is equal to DVD H times D H DT
which is the chain rule okay and the
answer is yes we can do that and indeed
that is what my next sentence is that's
exactly what I'm saying so when I said
this so sorry when you said this I did
that that's exactly what I did this
chunk is exactly DV d H that's just what
I'm doing okay so definitely that's
that's what I what I had in mind
yeah another question oh you're asking
me whether my arithmetic is right or not
what PI per second oh this should know
okay right I guess it's per minute since
the other one is per minute thank you
yes there was there another question
probably also fixing my seconds two
minutes way back
and why did you have to do all that
isn't the speed two cubic feet per
minute
the Z in which you're filling it is two
cubic feet but the water level is rising
at a different rate depending on whether
you're low down or high up it depends on
how wide the pond that the surface is so
in fact it's not in fact the answer
wasn't two cubic it wasn't that there is
a rate there that is that's how much
volume is being added but then there's
another number that we're keeping track
of which is the height or if you like
the depth of the water okay so this is
the whole point about related rates is
you have one variable which is V which
is volume of something you have another
variable which is H which is the height
of the cone of water there and you're
keeping track of one variable in terms
of the other and the relationship will
always be a chain rule type of
relationship so therefore you'll be able
to if you know one you'll be able to
figure out the other provided you get
all of the related rates these are what
are called related rates this is a rate
of something with respect to something
etc etc so it's really all about the
chain rule and just fitting it to two
word problems all right so there's a
couple of examples and I'll let you work
out some more all right so now the next
thing that I want to do is to give you
one more max min problem which is has to
do with this device which I brought with
me so this is a ring happens to be a
napkin ring and this is some parachute
string which I use when I go backpacking
and the question is if you have a you
think of this as a weight it's flexible
it's allowed to move along here and the
question is if I fix these two ends
where my two hands are where my right
hand is here and where my left hand is
over there then the question is where
does this ring settle down now it's
obvious or should be maybe obvious is
that if my two
hands are at equal Heights it should
settle in the middle all right
the question that we're trying to
resolve is what if one hand is a little
higher than the other all right what
happens over the other way where does it
settle down all right
so in order to depict this problem
appropriately I need two volunteers to
help me out can I have some help okay
so I need one of you to hold the right
side and one of you to hold the left
side okay and just just hold against the
black where we're going to trace so
stick it about here okay in the middle
somewhere right and now we want to make
sure that this one is a little higher
all right so I'll have to yeah let's get
it a little higher up that's probably
good enough all right so the experiment
has been done we now see where this
thing is but so now hold on tight this
thing stretches so we want to get it
stretched so that we can see what it is
properly when it's when there's so this
thing isn't heavy enough for this
demonstration I should have had a 10-ton
brick attached there but if I did that
then I would tax my right I would tax
your abilities - all right so we're
going to we're going to try to trace out
what the possibilities are here
all right so this is roughly speaking
where this thing and so now where does
it settle well it settles it settles
about here all right so we're gonna put
that as x marks the spot okay thank you
very much
whoa I've got to remember where it where
those dots were okay
all right okay sorry I forgot to mark
the spots okay so here's the situation
we have a problem and we we've hung a
string right and it went down like this
and then it went like that all right
and we discovered where it's settled
physically so we want to explain this
mathematically and see what's going on
with this problem so this is a real-life
problem it honestly is the problem you
have to solve if you want to build a
bridge like a suspension bridge this
among many problems it's a very serious
and important problem and this is the
simplest one of this type all right so
we've got our shape here this should be
a straight line maybe not quite as
angled as that all right
so now the first we've already drawn the
diagram and we more or less visualized
what's going on here but the first step
after the diagram is to give letters is
to is to label things appropriately and
I do not expect you to be able to do
this at this stage because it requires a
lot of experience but I'm going to do it
for you all right we're going to just do
that so the simplest thing to do is to
use the coordinates of the plane and if
you do that it's also easiest to use the
origin my favorite number is zero and it
should be yours too so we're going to
make this point be zero zero all right
now there's another fixed point in this
problem and it's this point over here
and we don't know what its coordinates
are so we're just going to give them
letters A and B but those letters are
going to be fixed numbers in this
problem all right
and we want to solve it for all possible
A's and B's now the interesting thing
remember is what happens when B is not
zero if B is equal to zero we already
have a clue that the point
be the center point it should be exactly
that X the middle point which I'm going
to label in a second is halfway in
between so now the variable point that
I'm going to use is down here I'm going
to call this point X comma Y all right
so here's my set up I've now given
labels to all the things on the diagram
so far or most of the things on diagram
alright so now what what else do I have
to do well I have to explain to you that
this is a minimization problem what
happens actually physically is that the
weight settles to the lowest point
that's the thing that has the lowest
potential energy so we're minimizing a
function and it's this curve here the
constraint is that we're restricted to
this curve so this is a constraint curve
and we want the lowest point of this
curve so now we need a little bit more
language in order to describe what it is
that we've got and the constraint curve
we accompli namely we strung some string
from here to there and what happens that
all these points is that the total
length of the string is the same all
right so one way of expressing the
constraint is that the length of the
string is constant and so in order to
figure out what the constraint is what
this curve is I have to describe that
analytically and I'm going to do that by
drawing in some helping lines namely
some right triangles to figure out what
this length is and what the other length
is so this length is pretty easy if I
draw a right triangle here because we go
over X and we go down Y so this length
is the square root of x squared plus y
squared all right that's the Pythagorean
theorem
similarly over here I'm going to get
another length which is a little bit of
a mess it's the it's the vertical so let
me just I'm just going to label one half
of it so you can see so this horizontal
distance is X and this horizontal
distance from this top point with this
right angle over there it starts at X
and ends at a all right the the
rightmost point is a in the x coordinate
so the whole distance is a minus X all
right so that's that's this leg of this
right triangle and similarly the
vertical distance will be B minus y and
so the formula here which is a little
complicated for this length is the
square root of a minus x squared plus B
minus y squared all right so here are
the the two formulas that are going to
allow me to set up my problem now so my
goal is to set it up the way I did here
just with just with formulas and not
with diagrams and not with names
okay so here's here's what I'd like to
do I claim that what's what's
constrained if I'm along that curve is
that the total length is constant so
that's this statement here the square
root of x squared plus y squared plus
this other square root these are the two
lengths of string is equal to some
number L which is constant and this as I
said is what I'm calling my constraint
yeah so the question is shouldn't it be
B plus y no and the reason is that Y is
a negative number it's below zero so
it's actually the sum - why is that is a
positive number
all right so here's here's the formula
and then we want to find the minimum of
something so what is it that we're
finding the minimum of this is actually
the hardest part of the problem
conceptually I've tried to repair it but
it's very hard to figure this out we're
finding the least what it's why we've
just got a name for that so we want to
find the lowest Y now the reason why it
seems a little weird is you might think
of Y is just being a variable but really
Y is a function it's really y equals y
of X is defined implicitly by the by the
by the constraint equation all right
that's what that curve is and notice the
bottom point is exactly the place where
the tangent line will be horizontal
which is just what we want so we from
the diagram
bottom point is where y prime is equal
to zero so this is the critical point
yeah
exactly so I'm deriving for you so the
question is could I have just tried to
find y prime equals zero to begin with
the answer is yes absolutely and in fact
I'm leading in that direction I'm just
showing you so I'm trying to make a
following very subtle point which is
when in maximum minimum problems we
always have to keep track of two things
often the interesting point is the
critical point and that indeed turns out
to be the case here but we always have
to check the ends and so there are
several ways of checking the ends one is
we did this physical problem we can see
that it's coming up here we can see that
it's coming up here therefore this the
bottom must be at this at this critical
point so that's okay so that's one way
of checking it another way of checking
it is that is the is the reasoning that
I just gave but it's really the same
reason I'm pointing to this thing and
I'm showing you that the bottom is
somewhere in the middle so therefore it
is a place of horizontal tangency that's
the that's the reasoning that I'm using
so again this is to avoid having to
evaluate a limit of an end or to use the
second derivative test which is a total
catastrophe in this case all right okay
now there's one other thing that you
might know about this if you've seen
this geometric construction before with
a with a string and chalk which is that
this curve is an ellipse it turns out
this is a piece of an ellipse it's a
huge ellipse these two points turn out
to be the so-called foci of the ellipse
however that geometric fact is totally
useless for solving this problem
completely useless if you actually write
out the formulas for the ellipse you'll
discover that you have a much harder
problem on your hands
and it will take you twice or ten times
as long so it's true that it's an
ellipse but it doesn't help okay so what
we're going to do instead is much
simpler we're going to leave this sprek
spreche '''l on and we're just going to
differentiate implicitly so again we use
implicit differentiation
on the constraint equation alright so
that's the equation which is directly
above me there at the top and I have to
differentiate it with respect to X so
that's a little ugly but we've done this
a few times before when you when you
differentiate a square root you the
square root goes into the denominator
and there's a factor of 1/2 so there's a
2x which cancels so I claim it's this
now because Y depends on X there's also
a YY prime here so technically speaking
it's twice this with 1/2 2 over 2 times
that all right so that's the
differentiation of the first piece of
this guy now I'm going to do the second
one and it's also the chain rule but I'm
just going to you're just going to have
to let me do it for you because it's
just a little bit too long for you to
pay attention to it turns out there's a
minus sign that comes out because
there's a minus X and a minus y there
and then the numerator the denominator
is the same massive square root so it's
a minus x squared B minus y squared and
the numerator is a minus X which is what
replaces the X over here and then
another term which is B minus y times y
Prime I claim that that's analogous to
what I did in the first term and you'll
just have to check this on your own
alright because I did it too fast for
you to be able to check yourself now
that's going to be equal to what on the
right hand side what's the derivative of
L with respect to X its 0 it's not
changing in the problem although my my
parachute stuff stretches we tried to
stretch it to its fullest extent so that
we kept it fixed
that was the goal here all right so now
this looks like a total mess
but it's not and let me show you why it
simplifies a great deal and let me show
you exactly how so first of all the
whole point is we're looking for the
place where y prime is zero so that
means that these terms go away Y prime
is equal to zero all right so they're
gone and now what we have is the
following equation it's X divided by
square root of x squared plus y squared
is equal to if I put it on the other
side I put the minus sign is changed to
a plus sign a minus X divided by this
other massive object a minus x squared
plus B minus y squared alright so this
is what it simplifies to now again that
also might look complicated to you but I
claim that this is something this is a
kind of equilibrium equation that can be
interpreted geometrically in a way that
is very meaningful and important so
first of all let me observe for you that
this X is something on our picture and
the square root of x squared plus y
squared is something on our picture
namely if I go over to the picture here
was X and this was a right triangle and
this hypotenuse was square root of x
squared plus y squared so if I call this
angle alpha then this is the sine of
alpha all right it's a right triangle
that's the opposite leg so this guy is
the sine of alpha
similarly the other side has an
interpretation for the other right
triangle if this angle is beta then the
opposite side is a minus X and the
hypotenuse is what was in the
denominator over there so this side is
sine of beta and so what this condition
is telling us is that alpha is equal to
beta which is the hidden symmetry in the
in the problem I don't know if you can
actually see it when I when I show you
these these is this thing but no matter
how I tilt it actually the the two
angles from the horizontal are the same
all right in the middle it's kind of
obvious that that should be the case but
on the sides it's not obvious that
that's what's happening all right now
this has even so that's a that's a
symmetry if you like of this situation
these two angles are equal
but there's something more to be said
if you do a force diagram for this what
you'll discover is that the tension on
the two lines is the same which means
that when you build something which is
hanging like this it will involve the
least stress if you hang something very
heavy and one side carries twice as much
load as the other then you have twice as
much chance of it's falling and breaking
if they all if they each hold the same
strength then you've distributed the
load in a much more balanced way so this
is a kind of a balanced condition and
it's very typical of minimization
problems and fortunately there are nice
solutions which distribute the weight
reasonably well and that's certainly the
principle of suspension bridges all
right so yeah one more question
okay so the question we're in hands that
is what the formula for X is and what
the formula for y is and other things
like the equation for the ellipse and
lots of other stuff like that those are
things that I will answer for you in a
set of notes which I will hand out and
it's there they're just a mess they're
there you see they're just as in that
other problem that we did last time
there's some illuminating things you can
say about the problem and then there's
some messy formulas you you know you
want to try to pick out the simple
things that you can say in fact that's a
property of math you want to focus on
the more comprehensible things on the
other hand it can be done it just takes
a little bit of computation alright so I
didn't answer the question of what the
lowest Y was but I'll do that for you
okay maybe maybe I'll just mention one
more thing about this problem so this is
a very amusing problem from a completely
different point of view if you sort of
roll the ellipse around you get the same
phenomenon from each place here so it
doesn't matter where a and zero zero are
you'll get the same phenomenon that is
the tangent line so the this angle and
that angle will be equal so you can also
read that as being that the angle over
here and the angle over here or equal
that is that is beta that is the
complementary angles are also equal and
if you interpret this as a ray of light
and this is a mirror then this would be
saying that if you start at one focus
every ray of light will bounce and go to
the other focus so that's a property
that an ellipse has more precisely
property that this kind of curve has and
in fact a few years ago there was this
great piece of art at the something
called the de Cordova Museum which I
recommend very highly to you go sometime
to visit when you're in your four years
here there was a collection of miniature
golf holes
they had a bunch of mini golf are pieces
of art and every one was completely
different the other one of them was
called hole-in-one and the tee was at
one focus of the ellipse and the hole
was at the other focus of the ellipse so
no matter how you hit the golf ball it
always goes into the hole just about no
matter where it bounces it's just one
bounce and it's in the hole so that's
that's kind of that's actually a
consequence of the of the computation
that we just did okay so time to time to
go on we're going to now talk about
something else all right
all right okay so our next topic our
next topic is Newton's method which is
one of the greatest applications of
calculus and I'm going to describe it
here for you and we'll illustrate it on
an example which is solving the equation
x squared equals five okay we're going
to find the square root of five now you
can actually solve any equation this way
any equation that you understand you can
solve this way essentially so so even
though I'm doing it for the square root
of five which is something that you can
figure out on your calculator in fact
this is really at the heart of many of
the ways in which calculators work so
the first thing is to make this problem
a little bit more abstract we're going
to set f of X equal to x squared minus
five okay and then we're going to solve
f of x equals zero so this is the sort
of standard form for solving such it so
you take some either complicated or
simple function of X linear functions
are boring quadratic functions are
already interesting and cubic functions
as I've said a few times you don't even
have formulas for solving so this would
be the only method you have for solving
them numerically so here's how it works
so the idea I'll plot this function
here's the function it's a parabola Y is
equal to x squared minus five it dips
below zero sorry it should be centered
but anyway okay and now the idea here is
to start with a guess
and square root of five is pretty close
to the square root of four which is two
so my first guess is going to be two
here
so start with initial guess alright so
that's our first guess and now what
we're going to do is we're going to
pretend that the function is linear
that's all we're going to do and then if
the function were linear we're going to
try to find where the zero is so if the
function is linear what we'll use is
we'll plot the point where two is on
that is the point x2 F of two and then
we're going to draw the tangent line
here and this is going to be our new
guess x equals x which we'll call X 1
all right
so the idea here is that this point may
be somewhat far from where it crosses
but this point will be a little closer
and now we're going to do this over and
over again and see how fast it gets to
the the place we're aiming for alright
so we have to work out what the formulas
are and that's the strategy
all right so now the first step here is
we have our guess we have our tangent
line which has the formula Y minus y 0
is equal to M X minus X 0 all right so
that's the general form for a tangent
line and now I have to tell you what X 1
is in terms of this tangent line X 1 is
the x-intercept the tangent line if you
look over here at the diagram the
tangent line is that is the orange line
where that crosses the axis that's where
I want to put X 1 all right so that's
the x-intercept now how do you find the
x-intercept you find it by setting y
equal to 0 that horizontal line is y
equals 0 so I set y equals 0 and I get 0
minus y 0 is equal to M times X 1 minus
X 0 so I change two things in this
equation I plugged in 0 here for Y and I
said that the place where that happens
is going to be where X is x 1 all right
so now let's solve and what we get here
is minus y divided by y 0 divided by M
is equal to X 1 minus X 0 and now I can
get a formula for X 1 right so X 1 is
equal to X 0 minus y 0 divided by M
all right now I now need to tell you
what this formula means in terms of the
function f so first of all X 0 is X 0
whatever X 0 is and y 0 I claim is f of
X 0 and M is the slope at that same
place so it's f prime of x 0 and this is
this is the whole story this is the
formula which will enable us to
calculate basically any root ok I'm
going to repeat this formula so I'm
going to tell you again what Newton's
method is and put a little more colorful
box around it so Newton's method
involves the following formula in order
to get the n plus first point that's our
a better and better guess I'm going to
take the enth one and then I'm going to
plug in this formula so f of X and
divided by F prime of X n so this is the
basic formula and this is if you like
this is the idea of just repeating what
I had before now we've gone from
geometry from just pictures to an
honest-to-goodness formula which is
completely implementable and very easy
to implement in any case all right so
let's see how it works in the case that
we've got which is x0 is equal to 2 f of
X is equal to x squared minus 5 so let's
see how to implement this this formula
so first of all I have to calculate for
you f prime of X that's 2x
and so x1 is equal to x0
- so f prime sorry f of X would be x0
squared minus 5 that's what's in the
numerator and in the denominator I have
the derivative so that's 2 x0 all right
and so all told well let's work it out
in two steps here this is minus 1/2 X 0
for the first term and then plus 5
halves over x0 for the second term and
these two terms combine so we have here
1/2 X 0 plus 5 halves with X 0 in the
denominator
alright so here's the formula for X 1 in
this case all right so now I'd like to
show you how well this works so first of
all we have X 1 is 1/2 times 2 if I plug
in X 0 plus 5/4 right which is 9 fourths
okay and X 2 I have 1/2 times 9 fourths
plus 5 halves times 4/9 all right that's
the the next one and if you work this
out it's 161 over 72 all right and then
X 3 is kind of long but I will just
write down what it is so you can see
it's 1/2 of 161 over 72 plus five halves
and then I do the reciprocal of that so
72 over 161 all right so let's see how
good these are all right I I carefully
calculated how far off they are
somewhere on my notes
just take a look see what I said oh yeah
I did do it okay so what's the square
root of five - but so here here's n
here's the square root of 5 minus X n if
you like or the other way around
the size of this you'll have to decide
on your homework whether it comes out
positive or negative and to the right or
to the left of the answer but let's
let's do this so when n is equal to zero
the guess was two and we're off by about
two times ten to the minus one and if n
is 1 so that's this 9/4 that's off by
about 10 to the minus 2 and then n is
equal to 2 that's this number here all
right and that's off by about 4 times 10
to the minus fifth that's already as
good an approximation to the square root
of 5 as you'll ever need in your life
okay if you do three this number here it
turns out to be accurate to 10 to the
minus tenth or so this goes right off to
the edge of my calculator this one here
so already with the third iterate you're
you're way past the accuracy that you
need for most things yeah question
how come he acts not disappears
hang on folks we have a question let's
just answer it so here we have an X 0
and here we have minus 1/2 there's an X
0 squared and an X which cancel Shh and
here we have a minus and a minus
five-halves X 0 so I combined the 1
minus 1/2 I got plus 1/2 that's all ok
all right thanks we'll have to ask other
questions after class